correct all right everybody thank you so
much for joining the stream really
excited about this next hour uh I'm here
with Todd krinsky uh for Reebok we'll
get into him I think I'm actually even
though we're very excited to talk about
the V friends uh incredible
collaboration with uh Reebok and then we
dropped the bomb because I know there's
a lot of v-friends holders we dropped
the bomb of the alpaca which is the star
of it on the v-friend shop there is a
little plus up and then reebok.com is
going to be the main other place to get
it uh before we do that we want to say
hello to all the names in here so tell
me where you're from say hello Liam good
to see you
um oh they're committing good Petey
gross great to see you Vicki always
great to see you
um tell me where you're at and what
platform you're on we've got twitch and
if you're like let's do hashtag which
family you're part of hashtag
twitchfamily linkedinfamily Facebook
family I know you're on a bunch of
different platforms I want to know which
platform you're on oh for God's in the
building yeah you know IG but IG live
should be happening on this yeah is it
not working no [__] the [__] Gus
not good is it because the token's not
catching but is a tick tock lot
happening or that so everything's
working but Instagram man let's go to
Instagram
um right lots of chat coming in Todd why
don't you uh why don't we kick this off
so let me let's set the same and we're
gonna go into entrepreneurial talk with
you we'll talk about the collab
uh I also want to make sure people from
the be friends team jump in and add
their two cents so Tyler or Daniel or
may or Andy will get you on stage as
well to talk about blocking and tackling
because even though the team always says
to me hey Gary here's what we want you
to talk about I get too excited Todd I
black out so I got these and F's in
school and I want to make sure we hit on
the main point so uh great man or woman
from V friends that's going to come in
and make sure we hit on All Points
please work with Eric and the rest of
team and make sure you pop up on stage
out of nowhere once you pop on the
screen I'll know to include you for now
we're going to talk about why we're all
here for a lot of you that are joining
that are uh not part of the uh the be
friends uh nft holding ecosystem or
paying attention to what we're doing
with trading cards and squishmallows and
collectibles uh we've been announcing
and this is the official kickoff to a
partnership with the iconic brand called
Reebok that we're extremely excited
about
um if you're following my socials I'm
starting to share some of this is the
classic Todd what is this what what is
this known as indesign-wise in Reebok
land again
in Reebok land that's the classic nylon
it's one of the most iconic classic
shoes in the Brand's history make you
super pumped we sent I sent a bunch of
pairs to like influencers many of which
are my more than acquaintances and some
are my actual friends
Amber Victoria for example an nft artist
who yeah Boehner met her husband here
David Zhang who was my brother's high
school friend who started here day one
she's now a very substantial nft artist
she wore them over the weekend and hit
me up she's like holy [__] the support
and comfort of this sneaker yeah she
went and bought other of her favorite
color schemes on the site so Kudos on
you on the biz Dev with me because I
think you're going to acquire some new
users even outside of the V Friends by
the way well the the cool thing about
this one is I think you're the first
person to do a collaboration on this
product and like ever I don't think I've
ever done one it's one of the most
iconic shoes but we've kind of kept it
so we haven't used it yet so anyone
that's getting involved in this now is
is getting involved an iconic product
that hasn't had a collaborator yet so
um perfect timing for it so super
excited about it obviously you know
um
just really excited to like do something
with something as iconic as Reebok you
know I see the comments in here we had a
great run with K-Swiss this came along
free agency like as you can imagine the
pump and the classic Reebok Leaf 80s so
big for me personally and then just the
just a partnership with you you know I
feel like I've been really excited about
that and that's what I want to start
with why don't we start with a few
minutes on Reebok and you a little bit
to set the tone for this the other call
out team we're going to start showing up
you know the team behind the scenes on
defense is putting up the links
um this is Trump is it dropping tomorrow
that's right like when are we like
officially again until tomorrow at 10
A.M so pre-sale tomorrow for the holders
though right pre-sale for holders yeah
so be friends Peppers get the first move
on that on on different shops we'll go
into the Super stickers for everybody
who's watching go to eBay and Google be
friends super stickers right now I think
you will be flabbergasted what's going
on so I think this little add up that
we've done is a big deal we'll go into
that but let's talk about well it's
funny it's funny because like I do a lot
of collaborations work with a lot of
celebrities and like I know when it's
going to be a real big thing when I get
certain texts from certain taste makers
just doing this for so long and you know
a lot of people respect a lot of the
stuff we do they like it but that top
top percent when I get this group but I
Got This Crew already kind of asking me
for it so I know what's going to happen
um I got to explain to them that they
can't get it yet because
different distribution and they're like
I want to mention names but some are
like come on man I'm like put in the NBA
10 years I should just get it I'm like
this is not how we're doing this one
it's a little different it's a little
different I know garyvee I sat Courtside
with it before a little different a
little different we're doing this one a
little different so I think I can start
to feel doing this for a long time when
the real hype and heat is coming and so
I think this one yeah uh maybe one of
them for sure
I do read the chat
I'm putting it in there Todd why don't
you tell everybody what's going on with
Reebok because obviously it got bought a
couple years ago now
um like what what you know actually just
introduce yourself what your role is
what you do and kind of like what what's
the state of the union of Reebok right
now
yeah yeah I'll be uh I'll be quick but
I've been a Reebok 30 years now man and
I think you know you and I talked before
I think one of the reasons I relate so
well to what you do is because I'm an
entrepreneur at heart and I think this
brand is very entrepreneurial a lot of
the things that you talk to young people
about today is very
um very consistent with how I kind of
operate but believe it or not man I
started um I'll give you the quick story
as I started working at Foot Locker when
I was 16 and then I I worked my way into
uh Reebok as a working in the mail room
and I hustled in the mail room for like
over a year just delivering mail trying
to meet people and then I actually
figured how long I could work nights at
Foot Locker and work for free during the
day and I ended up creating this coupon
and I put the coupon in every mailbox of
every executive at the company and I
said I can work four weeks for free just
give me a shot let me get out of the
mail room I'll do anything I'm so
passionate about this industry I was
selling pumps when I was 16 give me a
shot I was hustling and although I
Todd I gotta stop yeah I get people
complaining when I say do a hundred DMS
at night when you're just laying right
instead of just looking at like girls or
like guys or like like other random [__]
and like you just you brought me back to
47 year old self when I was 17 I had a
marketing idea for Wine Library
literally my dad had no marketing budget
so I printed a 20 off a case of wine
coupon on my computer and drove to the
Short Hills Mall because I was rich
small and like the [__] pieces of
papers on the [__] like what is the
windshield wiper [__] right in the
[__] sun on a day like this and did
that weekend after weekend and like now
all I'm asking people to do is take
their [__] phone
and just DM the places you want to work
and that's too hard for these
[__] yeah this was like this
was you're right on this [__] written
notes to these dudes well that's what I
was saying this was the 92 version of
Instagram you know what I mean this is
the point of making it wasn't the 92
version you and I had [__] we're all
that's right I had to like do this
design I had to put my picture in I
didn't even know what I was doing but
you're right but the hustle is what it's
all about I think there's so much more
access today but you're right people
would rather kids rather scroll and look
at [__] all day versus kind of like I
know I'm not old I fully don't feel old
I'm just trying to motivate one person
because right now who's like I don't
want to DM 100 people good then you're
not going to get an internship at
[__] Rock Nation or the NBA sorry
because somebody is doing it someone is
doing it yeah is doing it yeah and that
was that was what I was doing back then
and then I finally after like a year of
being in the mail room somebody offered
me a gig and they were like
I'm gonna make you an opportunity you
got to go to Thailand tomorrow and I was
like hi never been out of the country I
took the opportunity
I I did have a passport just because my
family's from Canada but I didn't I I
literally first place I've been outside
of Toronto and United States and um I
went to Thailand and uh I really got
immersed in the business came back and
then I I got a full-time gig and I
parlayed it from there and I was
involved in I was really involved in the
sports entertainment side for a while so
I worked I
um signed Alan Iverson to Reebok I was
involved a lot in a lot of the other
athletes that we signed I really learned
product and I moved to Korea for a while
this was another like my career has
never been like and this is one of the
things a lot of young people do today
they're like okay I'll do this for two
years and I'll level up to this and this
that [__] doesn't really matter like the
what matters is getting experience being
as fun so I did a lot of lateral stuff
where I wasn't making more money to go
do something else but I was like all
right yeah [__] it I'll move to Korea I
don't know where it really is and I've
never really experienced manufacturing
but I'd love to learn it so I feel like
I moved to Korea for three years learned
that came back and that was like my MBA
that was my MBA real quick I apologize I
see some series one holders that's
exactly right when we do these screens
down to all my channels when we do it on
meet.me friends it's the series one
holders the series two all the people
that own the nfts are going to be able
to ask the questions we're going to jam
here a little bit with Todd but leave
your comments Eric and the team are
going to put you in the back room you're
the ones that are actually going to be
able to be on stage a couple other
things be friends team please please
work feverishly in the comments I see a
lot of people asking questions because
I'm really looking to do content here
and not sell these like so I need you in
the in the comments linking to the links
one more time the free stuff starts
tomorrow but that's only for that's only
for be friends at FT holders then I
think and somebody from Team jump in and
maybe oh there we go Tyler look at you
listening to the assignment Tyler give
everybody real quick while we're jamming
an update on how this drop is happening
this limited edition drop on defense
website on Reebok's website break it
down real quick for the kids at home yes
so tomorrow 10 a.m ET the holder
exclusive pre-sale goes live for series
one and series two holders so if you're
looking to participate in that we
recommend setting up your reference
account now so then you have a nice
smooth process what happens what are the
costs and what happens for series one
and what happens for series two
um so they're eligible to purchase or
pre-order one pair of shoes per eligible
nft that they have so you have five
series twos you can order five pairs of
shoes
um the shoes are 90 a piece plus
shipping they come with obviously that
amazing super sticker that you had there
well that's cool that's on the befriend
side right because we did that for the
repairs that we have yeah Reebok has
more than us we expect our to kind of go
quickly with our community and obviously
again people that have uh no idea what's
going on with these super stickers
please go to eBay right now type in
v-friend super stickers you will think
we unveiled them at the national the
whole Trading Card thing the Pokemon
thing we unveiled the game a lot going
on in that world ask questions in the
comments because I know a lot of you
came for my text a lot of you are on
Instagram right now uh and different
things of that nature
um they'll so they'll be able to get one
pair pre-ordered from you know per nft
that they own how long does that last
that lasts until Wednesday at 10 A.M
Wednesday the 23rd and then it opens up
everywhere midnight on August 24th on
reebok.com and shop.b Friends it'll be
on reebok.com I know we took a big
allocation of the friends that dot com
because we wanted to really reward
people with the super stickers we got
pre-graded we got them graded we got
graded and they came in high most of
you're gonna get a random one but we got
pristines we got tens and mainly nine
fives there's like two nines I already
apologized up front for that person but
no 8.5 but Todd are people gonna be able
to find these pairs of speakers outside
of reebok.com because we should go
pretty quickly with our batch or did you
guys get them into other places in the
world or is exclusive on reebok.com so
for the first launch it's just it's just
you and us got it um and I don't know if
you remember this because this is what a
but really quickly a story how we came
to that we were meeting together and I
was like well if we want to go slower
then we have to sell it to other stores
it takes time we're on Futures and
you're like [__] it give them all to me
and I was like I was like well I want
some and you're like all right let's bet
on you and bet on me we bet on ourselves
and that's that's how the distribution
strategy came about
good and so right so I know we're trying
to do some other stuff and we'll go
broader with that I also know that you
know I want everybody here at us we've
heard loud and clear from Clear from the
uh squishmallows and the Reebok that we
have to do a better job of international
for our be friends community and so
we'll get ahead of that we'll start
talking to Todd about how we get that
done for future releases
um let's keep going Todd what what is
going on you know for mail yeah give
everybody the preview what is your title
right now
I'm the CEO president of the brand
think about that
for golf from mail room notes to give me
a job to now
what is the latest in grade
Reebok you know after the company has
you know there's the alpaca
what's this what's going on what are you
feeling well I mean I mean what's going
on right now is is total new
entrepreneurial getting Reebok back to
its rightful place I mean you know you
know authentic the the group
um I know you know them well so I mean
first of all just to be really clear
like under Adidas it was really hard
Adidas owned us for 15 years they were a
competitor they kind of you know owned
another competitive brand and they just
constricted us they didn't allow us to
do a lot they took a lot of things away
from Reebok and now we're able with ABG
with authentic with a great new
ownership it's very forward thinking and
their whole desire of why they acquired
Reebok was to bring it back to its
rightful place so that's what I'm doing
now
um being at the brand a long time I know
it well and so we're trying to get back
to being a disruptive a reverent Sports
culture brand like we used to be 90s
early 2000s you know before we were
acquired
um and it's my job to kind of create
that inspiration for the organization
for all our stakeholders world and
that's what I'm focused on it's like you
say it's like I'm less worried about the
competition and more worried about the
consumer something that you say a lot
and so I'm really focused on you know
what the consumer will expect from
Reebok and trying to drive that through
our company now so that's what I'm
focused on you've done a good job you
know I had like the full disclosure I
had a very great relationship with
K-Swiss the clouds and dirt I mean I see
them all around like people wear them to
my events and it was a great run it
expired I had leverage and wanted to
decide what I wanted to do and look I
spoke to everyone
yeah you know like you know I'm in a
very fortunate place in my career this
is important with this band specifically
it was very important for me to find the
right thing and you know full disclosure
you blew me away like you know back you
know now that I'm getting to know more
about your background we did a little
bit of pleasantries but it was more
about the business it makes sense like I
like that going from the from the
K-Swiss Club the clouds in the dirt
you've gone literally from the dirt to
the clouds but but it also had to do
with the iconic nature of the Reeboks
and look full disclosure just like I say
that I'm thrilled with like a Swiss you
know experience it just I wanted to find
something else and thought I wanted to
try something else
I'm I am actively like this is happening
in real time I am blown away by how
happy
the people that I've seen of this
product to are with the product yeah you
know Classics are just doing it yeah
Classics are on fire right now we're
really fortunate and I think the one
area that we have been able to drive
really strong is sports because the
Adidas took that away from us so we
gotta focus on Classics for sure but
then we really need to get back into
basketball which we're doing we're gonna
be back in the NBA next year we're
getting back into tennis golf all the
sports that we thrived in before but you
know one of the reasons why I think
everybody like this I apologize Tyler I
know I'm being a little ad hoc Tyler can
you jump back on because we do want to
talk about I apologize Todd yeah series
one holders of the nft alpaca in series
two holders of the nft alpaca starting
tomorrow in a very short window get a
very good situation you want to break
that down
yeah so the series one holders their
claim is open now they get one free pair
of shoes that ends tomorrow at 10 A.M
because I know a lot of me friends
community members here are if you've got
a friend who owns a series one alpaca
right make sure you get out I guess
that's 40 of them right there's four of
them 40
series one nfts with the alpaca you get
a free pair your claim is open right now
ends tomorrow and series two holders
because there's way more of those
series two alpaca holders get 50 off
that's during the pre-sale and the
public sale that's on shop.bfriends.com
and series some people are asking series
one holders go where to claim it
they can go to the they can go to our
homepage there's a little little link
out there's a banner that they can click
to the claim page
I know we have some people ready for
questions I'm gonna probably Jam for
another five here and we'll have them
prepared
uh so Tom go ahead you were saying no I
would I was just saying the reason why
we're so excited about this is because
you know in our industry collaborations
have got a little saturated you know
streetwear Brands Footwear Brands it's
happening every day I mean consumers
getting bored and I think you're looking
for new moves and this is really the
first brand to get into a space like
this it's a new move second you know
through all the research we know that
storytelling is so important capturing
the imagination which is what you do you
know not just having a kind of nft like
this but what it means the aspirational
aspect of this storytelling is really
rich and someone I don't know if
anyone's seen the content we put out but
it's really cool with three of your
members that told their stories of
aspiration like that's super cool and
that's what people are looking for not
just by the sneaker but buy into the
story that I think in the industry
storytelling is our currency and this is
like I think the Pinnacle of that and
then I think the last one is
distribution like just don't get lazy
and just give it to every retailer
that's what we've done we've come up
with a distribution that's really cool
and that's what you're talking about now
so I think for us the reason why we're
so excited about this is because it hits
on the mark of I think where collab
collaborations are going for our
industry
appreciate it brother uh that's um a
couple things a lot of questions about
buying series one and series two V
friends a lot of people should be
linking in the chats uh number two I see
a lot of questions about the super
stickers look again raw super stickers
are like 20 bucks 30 bucks there's a lot
of rare alpacas there's a lot of people
in the chat right now that are deep into
V friends super sticker culture but like
yes there were some people just asked
questions that are doing homework I'm
like wait a minute I see some super
stickers that are not even graded
selling for thirty forty dollars you're
telling me the pair of sneakers is 80
bucks and I get in one of these graded
with it the answer is yes and so the
vfriends.com buying of this that comes
with the super stickers is gonna be a
pretty big deal for full clarity the
Reebok side does not come along with
those super Savers we have blog posts
that explain all this team please share
all links like pound every chat with
links pin them everything
um the Gary channels other places let's
make sure people are heavily educated
let's on all the different options if
they're a holder if they're not a holder
how do they buy an nft to get the
opportunity somebody just asked wait a
minute so I can get 50 off
a pair so that's a 40 savings if I buy
an alpaca the F2 on the open market
that's right so if you're thinking about
getting your first be friend you get to
Arbitrage that way
um but let's get that first question in
for me and Todd you can go anywhere with
entrepreneurship aspiration is the theme
of the uh of the alpaca we have a great
piece of content up there she is
hey Gary
hey guys so I I hope you didn't cover
this already I got a backup question if
not but Todd why did you pick the alpaca
and what other characters maybe did you
consider before deciding on the alpaca
oh man well first of all we're hoping to
do more so there's there's more options
coming although I don't I don't know if
I can say anything but um
I apologize everybody I've always said
80 before my brain broke yeah Todd jump
in any time to fix me they are 90 I
apologize go ahead
I think the main reason is because what
I said earlier is this idea around
storytelling we felt like this idea of
her aspiration was so cool and we felt
like let's give it to the community to
express
Express theirs you know and that's what
those three content pieces are so I
think it was just the message it was the
message that we chose on that one um but
there's a few others that we really
think are interesting that I think may
find their way into our partnership so
we'll see what happens for me don't
forget be friends and you may know this
in a small group on your nose epren's
actually started as workplace Warriors
right in 2018 and the concept was these
little toys on a desk when you're having
a shitty day and your boss is a dick and
you look down and you're like well I'm
great I'm grateful for my family being
healthy even though I'm having a bad day
at work with sneakers you look at them
so much like you don't even realize you
look at your sneakers a lot by accident
like tie your shoe like me on planes put
up my feet and for me like there's a
really cool thing it was funny we were
like talking about making a piece of
content for promotion and then me then
then the team was like no no we filmed
this talk that you had the other day in
the office with Sid and Andy talking
about it I'm like that's going to be the
piece of content and I was and I'm
excited to see what it looks like
because I just talked a lot about like
are you aspiring for your life like like
as we all sit here today are you like
for example Todd Todd created his
professional reality right if you're a
male kid male wounded kid hustling like
that to get the CEO of that brand like
he's done that but
maybe he there's some things he wants to
do in philanthropy maybe there's some
things he wants to do with his family
that he's not doing maybe there's some
cult back to business maybe there's you
know he's rebooting this brand there is
clearly listen I'm even just listening
to him right now there's something he
wants to accomplish in the NBA that has
not been accomplished yet so right for
all of us what I'm pumped about this
Laura is like I feel like when the be
friends and the broader this product for
example is going to broaden be friends
because many of the garyvee people
watching right now are going to buy this
pair of sneakers for 90 bucks just
because it's a [__] good piece of
like sneaker right like they just like
green and they like the classics and
they're kind of in that place of like
well [__] it I need a new pair of
sneakers they look fresh I'd [__] with
Gary let me pick one up
what I'm excited about that is they're
just going to look down and remember
what we're talking like I genuinely
believe that somebody randomly is
watching right now they got the text
from my text thing has no idea about be
friends is kind of about me not even
like a deep Gary fan watching this is
about to hear this and realize it's true
which is
they just might buy this pair of
sneakers they're going to remember this
stream it's gonna be December 9th
they're gonna look down at this little
[__] alpaca right here right
they're going to know at this point that
it's the aspiring alpaca and they're
literally going to ask themselves like
am I living my life the way I want to
live like and they like number ninth put
in their resignation and 2024 is the
beginning of the rest of their lives for
me I like being in business I like doing
business deals like this but when you
know that one to 100 people are gonna do
what I just said because of it that's
when I get the email on a long flight
you know like I've been doing a lot of
those I got two more I've got Brazil and
Saudi Arabia this month you catch up
with your work then I start reading the
[__] that's what's exciting for me on
this and that's why we I wanted the
alpaca because I think it's going to
challenge people when they take off
their shoes at night when eighty percent
of people did not have a good day it was
just a [__] day whatever day a bad
day I'm hoping they [__] remember
this moment which maybe triggered them
to buy it and say like I gotta change my
[__] up and I think that's cool you know
like people wear sneakers for different
reasons fashion you know it's the
coolest thing you want to position
yourself is cool it's a form of
expression but the fact that I think we
can
you know actually change someone's life
too is kind of cool
yeah
I just think it's so fresh in the
collaboration spiceler I don't know how
close you follow it but so many brands
are working with Brands and they're just
taking one logo and putting it on a
sticker and that's it there's no message
starting to Gary's Point like this is a
cool message about pushing people to to
Aspire to what they really want to do
and maybe it does change one person but
it's also the logo looks pretty cool in
the shoe it's a very cool design that I
think fits the shoe well too but that's
secondary but we are in the fashion
business so that helps
people are asking about the heel support
yeah I mean it's it's basically one of
the original original running shoes so
it's a really soft soft Eva it's got a
strong heel counter so I mean for the
value you know it doesn't have like like
visible technology but it's built for
one of it's one of the most comfortable
shoes you will wear trust me on that
um
more questions Laura thank you
Rob gracious oops see Rob
these are some of these Reebok Classics
right question mark oh there's Robin
yeah yep Rob how are you how are you and
you're very tall you know family members
oh we we are great uh what a day what a
day and so to go along with the aspiring
alpaca Todd real quickly two and a half
years ago decided to follow Gary's game
plan that he puts out there for free me
and my family wanted just to do videos
as a brand two and a half years later
we're over three billion views I got wow
I got to dunk at Shaq's house no way I'm
sitting my Shaq's watching my son play
basketball sitting there talking and my
kid hits a three and he ribs me and then
he dunks and Shaq's like okay so anyway
and so anyway so I'm just gonna come
right out this is extremely right hook I
love Gary he's changed my life when it
comes time to storytelling to be more
human which I know Reebok's all about we
are we live in a small town in the
midwest I have two uh son and a daughter
both starting College this fall they
both played basketball we're building
okay we're building a pickleball court
in the backyard we are the house that
everyone comes to we all hang out so
anyway when Reebok wants to and I and
I'm all for like hey go NBA of course
all that but when you want to be more
human we are the everyday average family
we just happen to be taller than most
families
tell Todd the heights
so 7-1 my my son uh now I'm six six uh
my daughter who's 14 is 6'2 so she's
still growing and then I have uh my
other daughter is only five ten so she's
like the short one of the family I paper
plan
es
watch this Rob send me a full pledge
email of your pitch and I will
personally hand deliver it to Todd
the one the one reason I like it is
because the NBA is only part of the
basketball culture these days I think
it's more about community and basketball
culture than it is just having the NBA
guy I think that's part of it but as we
strategize to get back in the NBA a year
from now one of the things we're talking
about is community and interesting
stories and um ironically enough Shaq is
my partner on this so he's nuts I think
he calls me
he's probably has as much energy as Gary
and he calls me almost probably once
every two days with an idea
um so he's been my partner as we get
back into basketball and he's also
seeing that NBA is only part of what we
do so shoot it to Gary and let's see
what happens yeah so if you talk to him
tell me talk to the dad of seven foot
one redhead Carter he he knows Carter
he's still asking about him so thank you
okay I will I will this might be a
detail interview and by the way Jeremy
or Andy or or Tyler on my team you can
jump in do we know the size ranges that
we're launching this with
thanks Rob we can take Rob off add in
somebody from the the Friends team to uh
to give us an answer on that because
there's a lot of questions about sizes
obviously that'll become more obvious as
we yeah put it out
um
Tyler yeah five men to 14 men
3.5 so that and because it's unisex like
we'll take care of yep it's unisex so it
basically covers the entire men's and
women's range after 14 that's gonna be
good there's I don't think we went to 14
on on the clouds and dirt I think we
only got to 13 so yeah so 3.5
to 14.
yeah I don't know if the tall family's
been in the 14. they might be up in the
16 17 years like I know some people go
wide these have taught is this right the
classics like some of my friends like
that normally have to really shop for
wide said that it like went wider than
they expected like it worked for them it
was like it was like a wide shoe but it
had flexibility to the left and right is
that right yeah this one especially
because it's a nylon suede upper it's
not a like a harder rigid Leather So the
classic nylon was always made for a more
Universal wear because it's a little it
gives a little more give it looks like
give and this and people were asking
about this would is this considered
white and off-white
yeah it's like an off-white suede so
it's not a pure Pure White which gets
dirty really quick it's kind of an
off-white
yeah yeah that being said I've been
rocking these like I got my dirty very
quick so like but I'm also from a
disaster like I'm like the worst like I
beat the [__] out of everything so I
shouldn't be like I'm like running
through the grass I'm doing all sorts of
[__] up [__] so I don't know if yeah
but you know White is you got to keep it
tight all right let's get somebody in
there we go
hello hello Gary hello Todd hello
from England near Bristol excuse me
so yeah Todd how did you first find out
about V friends and do you have any of
the nfts yet
well I I found out about just I follow
Gary for a really really long time
um
just because I've I grew up in this
business learning from a guy named Paul
fireman he started Reebok actually he
bought it from um the UK so he bought it
from a company in the UK and brought it
to the US he was basically selling shoes
out of his trunk and that's how I
learned the business and so I've always
had a like an eye for entrepreneurs and
Gary's message was just very relevant to
me even though I was you know at the
senior management company and running a
company his his message is I think
Universal as it rates to
entrepreneurship so so I've known him
for a really long time and then just got
to know the friends
um through him so through all this
energy you know
my son and I have been talking about
buying we haven't purchased yet so I
think I'm gonna be on it now so I don't
own one yet for sure way to close the
deal for us Connor good [__] there you
go I got it you'll get Commission on it
so thank you very much
yeah nice to meet you guys thank you
have a great great night all right let's
get some questions going again to give a
recap uh actually Tyler jump in I think
you're doing a nice job on the on the
recap come in and give us the hardcore
of everything that's happening and I'll
add a little comment color commentary to
the super stickers that are going on
what's that Gary sorry I was tough to
hear you backstage no worries brother uh
just give everybody a lot of people are
coming in and out of the Stream So I
think it's time for another update on
like what's going on what are we doing
here when are we dropping these what's
the pre-sale who can buy the pre-sale
when's it broad Market where can you buy
it what's the price
price is ninety dollars per pair that's
across the board
these are the V friends aspiring alpaca
classic nylon
um pre-sale goes live this is exclusive
to befriend series one and befriend
series two holders this pre-sale goes
live at 10 A.M tomorrow that's through
Wednesday on the 23rd at 10 A.M and then
at midnight on August 24th is when the
shoes go live to the public so they go
live on job.b friends.com as well as
rebike.com so if you guys are
international you'll want to buy off
reebok.com and then shop.b friends is
fulfilling us only right so reebok.com
is going to be able to take
International right because and and
which markets are best shipping costs
Todd do you know that off the top of
your head
um definitely Europe definitely Europe
and some pockets of Latin America
um but yeah it'll be reebok.com and then
that's the only two places you can get
it right now and and then maybe in the
future and we know this is gonna smoke
pretty quick maybe in the future Gary we
choose some key retailers that we'd like
to partner with but yeah you know for us
I think we knew that we wanted to get
this in this year I think as yeah as
this relationship grows I think
Australia is going to matter Asia's
gonna matter we'd probably have to pick
a key retailer or two in there and then
for everybody who's asking the questions
a couple of add-ons to what Tyler just
said if you own the aspiring alpaca
series one
um this is a series two let me just have
to show it to you if you're on the
series one design there's 40 of them in
the world you get a free pair you can
claim them on befriends.com right now if
you own the series 2 which there's like
uh 220 of those there might be people
that hold multiples you'll be able to go
and get 50 off
on a pair
um and that starts and then
on.com for our limited Supply we went
ham as many people know these super
stickers have exploded everybody who's
watching right now should go to eBay go
to beef type in V friends super stickers
um and go look at completed items they
become a major collectible they're in
the old 80s vending machine style the
raw ones at least
um are going between two twenty and six
hundred dollars a piece the rare robot
being the 600 one we took an extra step
and got game pre-graded
and most of them came back a 9.5 a 10 or
even a pristine 10 like these for
everybody who buys on vfriends.com it
we're gonna shift along one of these
with your pair
mainly because I always like thinking
about like how do you win twice right
Tyler's you know graded super stickers
right now
one could argue you're either getting
the sticker or the pair of sneakers for
free at 90 bucks given the current
market so I know there's a lot of Savvy
friends card and sticker collectors we
saw them come out hard at the national
big shout out to Dalton you did a really
nice job it paid like a month's worth of
rent by hustling and buying them off the
people that got in the bags
um and so wanted to give a big
opportunity for the hardest score be
friends collectors and holders so they
can attack our site and get those out of
the way inventory wise and then Reebok
will be the home of it internationally
and everywhere else so anyway that's
where we're at with that
yeah one small thing for not a small
thing but a cool thing with the super
stickers is the Rarity component built
in with the different backgrounds ahead
of you this is literally out of ten this
is the first time this is the most rare
uh out of 10 black ice
so if you're buying on people.com this
is the one you're praying you get it's
gonna be completely randomized so that
one's gonna be out of 10. the
um the pink ice is out of 199.
199 on the pink ice
the uh green ice is at a 399
limited 3.99 again when you order on
befriends.com they will come the gold
ice is out of 99 so this is the second
one you're hoping for you're hoping for
the black or the gold
and then finally the red ice out of 299
so there's Rarities there's blog posts
to all of this
um again for the people that have been
flipping v-friends cards and stickers
you know what this Arbitrage is we
originally were just going to put the
raw one in because there's really that
20 to 80 range on those you took it the
next step we decided to grade them all
the great we were praying because
they're brand new we thought we can get
ones that would breed well it went crazy
two of you are going to be very unlucky
you'll get the two rated to nine and the
rest of you are getting nine fives tens
or ten christines which are really rare
from cgc so we're really excited about
that part all the befriends community
and all the different chats LinkedIn
Facebook Instagram well Instagram's
there uh YouTube let's make sure we link
up everything so people can figure this
out because I think for the flip life
people they're gonna take advantage of
that if they're paying attention zebra
how are you
you get one sticker for sale if you buy
three pairs you'll get three stickers
zebra how are you
we can't hear you brother
something on your end my brother
because it doesn't look like you're
muted you know we'll work on him we'll
get somebody else out
um
Todd what else is going on with uh let's
just get Reebok a little love because
again I Feel Like A lot's going on what
uh what's been uh interesting or
exciting for you
I think right now just the future plans
I mean like what other like take a nap
like I'm pumped to do it like what other
clubs are hot what else is going on oh I
think someone's in yeah I think
Michelle's joining us
what's up guys I'm excited to be here
thank you again for everybody who's
asking
com it blasts everywhere but the people
that are able to get on it because it's
on be friends they can see that you own
an nft and those are gonna be the people
that get to ask questions uh we're gonna
extend that as we relaunch tea with
garyvee uh so I think it's gonna be a
really fun part of that community and
I'm excited to see that so Michelle tell
everybody where you're from which
befriend you own and then ask a question
awesome I am in Nashville Tennessee I
have five uh v1s I have the joyous
jellyfish the genuine giraffe which was
my very first nft
um caterpillar the daring dragonfly and
[__] I can't remember the last one yes
the giraffe is by far my favorite
character look everybody's got like a
least favorite child so that's what
happened with
you it is yeah
okay what's your question Todd your
story is super inspiring but my question
is all about the flip life like right so
I own five v1s 19 V2s How many pairs of
sneakers do I buy because the blog says
despite being limited Supply is enough
for both loyal community and new
audience so if I want to do the flip
life well I mean it depends on like
here's what I would say to everybody
who's thinking about flip life I think
there'll be enough of the sneakers and
like there will be more demand for like
look we made it in a way that I expect
especially based on what this is why I
was why I chose Reebok I thought Todd
was
was more bought in back to how he
answered the question earlier like I
could sense that he had a sense of me I
felt more connected
the new owners of Reebok is a family I'm
very close to I know the Salters well
so I felt like I'd be quote unquote
taken care of which is why I assume they
went with one of their strongest
Silhouettes because I you know I really
when you're in a partnership you want to
be a good partner so I said to them you
show me the sneakers you're thinking so
I think the sneaker Demand on its own is
going to be there especially with the
influencers that are marketing it
working so on the flip life I do expect
this the V friends.com sales to go very
fast because you're in it Michelle and
you know the super stick the super
stickers are going crazy right they're
going crazy yeah they are and so like
look you get a [__] black ice or gold
you'll be out and it grades well you
know this these I mean you get the black
ice people pay for 50 pairs right now
that's also playing the lottery so I
don't recommend that I I would say flip
life I the answer is I don't know and
honestly after the year I had a couple
years ago with speculating around nfts
and going further than I should have in
my own opinion like like look long term
I think I'm building a massive IP I
literally took a flight to London for
one meeting for a few friends and flew
back damn my commitment to what I'm
doing is insane Comic Cons coming the
national you saw right really focused on
a lot of nft innovation in 24 and 25. so
you know here's the problem with flip
life
I've learned that I think about flip
in 10-year windows
I've learned almost everyone thinks that
flip life in 10 10 day Windows right my
my point of view the stickers has a very
high opportunity but I don't know okay
first
there should be a like I feel like like
again I feel confident I mean we made
way less than we did with K-Swiss
okay yeah yeah I feel like we've
produced in a manner but it's not like a
hundred like there's four digits in the
numbers out there not not five so you
know I don't know on the sneaker front I
really don't and I don't want to
speculate I on the stickers I just know
what's going on on eBay right now it's
like and it's like there's only gonna be
a like there's only a thousand of them
right so it's not super complicated and
especially because they're numbered they
tear out if you quote unquote get lucky
it could get really good that is always
a bad strategy in flip life that's a
lottery ticket right right but in the
way I think about this project I
definitely think long term I'm building
a real IP and
you know it all just depends on how
people think about it so I you should
definitely get a pair of [__]
[__] I'm getting two for myself one
to where and one to hold so for sure I'm
buying two at least
I mean I think the whole distribution
question is a really good one I think we
there's a formula you know you sign like
a music artist or a basketball player
you sign up with a sports uh like a
streetwear brand you kind of know what
the pair should be
um this is a little different and we
definitely want to really be clear on
the supply and the demand and keep the
special special out of the product and
we may do more jobs together so we
wanted to kind of keep it tight we're
also not allowing any
um retailers to buy into it yet although
we got requests when the pr went out so
I think um to Gary's Point they'll be
enough but there there are there won't
be any left I guess that's the best way
to put it I will say that people that
are like really about for life
can you speak to this Todd because
kind of wore them for for a week I'm a
disaster I like played literally like
the party easy
three or four because like you kind of
like are they easy to clean or no
well just like they're not as easy as a
leather suit leather shoe is a lot
easier to clean but there are a lot of
suede cleaners right now and you can
throw them in the washing machine which
is another thing that's tougher to do
with leather so there are ways to clean
it but it's definitely it's like an NBA
player you can buy 30 pairs so you can
wear a new pair every day
my rule you always have to have a fresh
pair you never know you always have to
be fresh and I need them fresh for v-con
and that's far away so what's up love
you great to see you thank you thank you
guys up here milk some time with the
community
again if you want to get up here these
are only for be friends holders they go
to meet upbeatfriends.com that's how
they get in there he is the legend can
you hear me now am I good
good awesome all right Gary great to see
you again
talk to you for the first time
um had a quick question uh specifically
around the you know the aspiring and the
expansion back into sports into the
sports realm so yeah Olympics in 2024
it's in Paris it's including break
dancing again you know for the first
time and we're really excited about that
so USA breaking is a national you know
501c3 or Paving the way for breaking in
the United States and we Breakers have
always robbed Reeboks right it's part of
our culture so what would it look like
if Reebok were to collab with some
breakers and is there a possibility for
sponsorships or spot you know sponsor
athletes
with LA coming up in 2028 you know
that's our home turf like we really want
to you know kind of rock out and
represent here and would love to have
Reebok you know supporting
yeah so I love the idea I worked very
much into you know what you would call
non-traditional Sports as we move get
back into sport right now we are talking
to
um one
um break dancer from Europe and one from
the US okay um right now in talks
um on some collaboration Reebok Reebok
Classics have always been synonymous
with break dancing for sure so
um and we're more and we're open to kind
of how this could work so absolutely
we're already kind of looking at a
little bit so and we're trying to learn
more we're trying to learn more for sure
and zebra do me a favor email me to Gary
ener X
vaynerx.com vaynermedia well in August
the same place you can get something to
Gary defense too
um we're vaynermedia works with Visa we
are activating like crazy at the 24
Paris Olympics with them we won the
Olympics marketing pitch with them yep
and we actually have break dancing part
of our activations and influencers
inbreed deacons globally yeah and so I
might be able to help you on that front
brother awesome awesome really
appreciate that yeah thank you so much
thank you brother oh everybody you own
oh [__] okay so uh the reason I might
see I'm zebra is anonymous is because I
went heavy and hard on zebra so I picked
up all five zebra specs and the two
zebra epics so I've got seven zebras
where do you live uh East Coast
you have the series one zebra rainbow
yes and I have the Emerald series too so
I've got literally series one series two
iconic everything I did I don't I I knew
you were ham but I didn't realize you
had the full rainbow uh oh send me that
email and break dancing I'll use that
for where my brain was going on
something else yeah yeah awesome perfect
thank you so much good to meet you nice
to meet you nice to meet you too Todd
tell people more about the quality of
the sneaker there's a lot of comments
coming through that are just like hey
you know love garyvee not sure about the
v-friend stuff but like just need a new
pair of sneakers so I figured let's
spend a few minutes on the quality of
the sneaker like what what is the
silhouette what is it like whatever you
got on the classics
on this one yeah I mean so this is
literally one of the most timeless
Silhouettes in the industry not just
Reebok
um it's got a really really soft Eva
bottom um it was originally made Believe
It or Not in the late 80s for running
we've kept kind of all the details of it
um but just made it a little more modern
with the materials and the kind of shape
of it but it is one of the most classic
I think comfortable Styles you will wear
in the industry
um and it's it's you know it's over 30
years old we just you know we sell a lot
of it but we haven't done a
collaboration with it yet um I think
waiting for for the right kind of
Storytelling and this is it but you
can't go wrong man I mean it takes color
really well
um the suede nylon upper is really fresh
um so absolutely it's a must buy it's a
must buy if you don't have a pair
everyone should have a classic nylon in
their closet for sure man for sure I
agree that's another question up here
while we go into the back end of this
live stream so yes
my man great to see you brother
oh you're on mute it's the perfect
person for this
oh can you hear me yeah great job
what a great guy everybody's watching
who's not familiar with this man you
should be go ahead
I think so scary um hi tugs it's nice to
meet you and really awesome inspiring
tutorialis eating lunch with my wife and
hearing your story my wife was like wait
he was a guy in the mail room and then
he became CEO she was just shocked I
think you're
um so my question is
how did you get into web 3 world and
now that you're a CEO
what do you aspire to be or what are
some things that you aspire to do next
five 10 years and I think that's same
for Gary but I think we all know he Gary
you wanna
make this difference into like a Disney
or Pokemons so but I love to hear some
I'll jump real quick so Todd has a lot
of time okay I'm glad you said that I
think you you've probably heard this I
originally thought Disney but the reason
I now say Sesame Street meets Pokemon is
I want competitive and collectibles
competition and collectibles to be a big
part of be friends those are two things
I love but once I realized Jim Henson's
Vision with Sesame Street to make the
world more inclusive like I want to make
the world more purple and I mean that by
America's very red and blue right now
there's extremes and I think all the
Magic's in the middle I don't believe in
any police trophies but I also believe
there's never a time not to be nice
things like that and so excited about
that you probably make a positive impact
on the world
um and so yes I'm I'm working on this
for the rest of my life as you know in
the nft market has had a massive
correction we're definitely a very down
market and I've you know again I flew to
London for one meeting so
absolutely literally Monday night 11 p.m
flew to London landed the day it started
there showered had a long meeting had a
break to do conference calls and board
meetings that I was supposed to do
yesterday in New York met with the
people I met for the meeting for dinner
and then woke up this morning at 4 AM
and flew back to New York went to Jets
training camp ran over here showered did
this live stream like you're only doing
that if you're off the [__] rock or
obsessed right I did that because the
meeting that I had and accomplished
which is even better because you're
taking the risk when you do something
like that it's gonna have a massive
impact on this IP and I'm excited
they'll materialize into next year but
like you know these are the things I'm
doing behind the scenes this is an
opportunity to share a story like that
as you could tell I haven't really been
sharing a lot of the building block
stories but they're manifesting in the
ridiculously successful National the
Comic-Con we got coming up this Reebok
collaboration you know again if you read
the comments actually watch this
everybody in the comments how many
people
do not own a v-friend
but we'll be getting a pair of these
Reeboks please say yes in the comments
um you know and that will come in a
second because there's a delay but like
that you know extending the IP so that's
what I'm up to Todd you
I mean listen we're in a very unique
really cool position right now you know
this brand has finally been Unleashed
from being owned by a competitor and so
my goal is to make this brand great make
it get its back to its rightful place be
a disruptive sports brand you know I
don't think the I don't think the
industry just needs another sports brand
playing up the middle man like there's
enough of those brands that kind of show
you the athletes show you the shoe you
know and talk tell the kid to be like
LeBron James or be like whoever I don't
think and I don't I don't think the
market needs another brand like that
you've got to be disruptive you got
challenges to ask quote if you look at
Reebok back in the day that's what
you're a little younger but back in the
day that's what Reebok used to do man we
were always like you know we were
signing out on Iris and taking a risk we
went to Jay-Z and said let's do a
sneaker together even though it doesn't
exist in the industry we did all that
[__] and I lived it and so I think Gary
the city's kind of off The Rocker crazy
I think is what he said I'm similar I'm
a niacal about this Mission and my goal
is to try to inspire all the people that
work for me and all the retailers around
the world to get behind a brand that I
think has an opportunity to really do
something different in Industry this is
what I kind of live and breathe every
day and I feel it I taste it I know what
it was like back before and that's what
I'm trying to do right now you know as
far as how this whole world fits into
our future we're still learning man you
know I mean this is really interesting
to be even on this this cat this live
stream today just to see the community
to understand the culture and as we move
forward I think we're going to try to do
more of this but it would be really
um I'd be reaching to tell you how we
see it in the future until we learn more
about how this really works but this is
exciting this is the first time anything
like this has happened man when you've
got all of these Community people like
yourself coming on you're really you
know you're into this culture you're
buying and now Reebok comes in how does
this whole thing work I think it's going
to be really a lot for us to learn so we
could get better as we go and I think
it's another thing that Gary and I talk
about it's like yeah edit and amplify as
you go the next [__] we do will be
probably better than this just because
we're going to learn from everybody
that's right thank you so much thank you
thanks so much thank you good to meet
you take care we're wrapping up here in
four minutes
um I uh
I'm pretty excited about this man just
really nice to be with you
God I'm like I really feel like we're
gonna need to get that Tyler up here to
recap touch you yeah
yeah
[Music]
garyvee what's up brother
good to see you man so happy to be uh
Beyond here on the show thank you
brother what's cooking let's get a quick
question because we're wrapping up in
four
copy so my question uh to you
specifically is you mentioned that you
were shopping the shoe around for a long
time before we hit with Reebok and now
it's out so what is that time frame and
I'm asking this question so that we know
you know the surprise and Delight that
you do I know you have so many irons in
the fire like what's the timeline that
we should expect for another thing
for Todd the question is
after I took a full year off after the
K-Swiss and just was like I'm not even
gonna look and I started taking meetings
Todd do you recall when we had our first
meeting
uh I think it was like a year ago I
think it feels like maybe even a hair
more I need 14 months maybe maybe yeah
yeah early summer
yeah so JBC it was probably like a year
off then it was like 6 or 12 months of
just different meetings with different
brands
and then 14 months ago the meeting with
Todd and that back to the point of like
it takes time for certain things to like
get the market so that's it brother
they're a little blurry so we're gonna
take you off but thank you brother
and some deals come together quicker six
to 18 months depending on the nature of
it
all right Tony yeah I also think one of
the things one of the things that made
this go a little quicker Gary is we
decided to go direct to Consumer and
that makes it go a little faster you
don't have to deal with retailers and
shipment and all this so you can go
faster with our distribution strategy hi
everybody in uh YouTube asking where
they can buy it let's let's wrap this up
Tyler's you talk we need everybody
behind the scenes putting up the URLs uh
my team let's make sure I tweet right
now no uh sit I forgot a bunch of you
could Instagram I love you switch over
to YouTube or something else let's get a
tweet out with all the links from the
get like let's get that going out just
uh let's put that out for my account
with all the links here are the updates
of the four links you need to know about
the live stream that just went down last
hour so everybody watching I will put
out a tweet right now in the next two
minutes three minutes that has all the
links with all the information but Tyler
recap us here a little bit
cool so for the drop there's two dates
and two locations you need to know the
first date is the holder exclusive
pre-sale that goes live tomorrow at 10
A.M eastern time because I know a lot of
people are not holders these are people
that own beef runs nfts is that series
one in series
two yeah
yeah all those holders can order one
pair of shoes per nft that they own if
you have a series two alpaca you're also
eligible for 50 off we'll be sending
those emails with your discount codes
prior to the pre-sale
right now click and get their free pair
series one right
yep that's correct those holders also
receive an email today so check your
inboxes and you'll have the direct link
to click yes per alpaca is
yep
um for everybody else the sale goes live
August 24th at midnight that's on
reebok.com and shop.bfriends.com
shop.vfriends.com is fulfilling us only
so if you're International you'll want
to go to reebot.com and pick up your
shoes there they're 90 per pair
when it goes to the public or to if it
just sells out with the holders
um you will be getting an exclusive
super sticker go to ebay.com
so type in V friends super stickers or
go on Twitter and see under my tweets
the community uh actually everybody
who's deep in the cards and super
stickers Community when I post this post
about what's going on with all the
Reebok stuff reply with all the links to
what's going on with super stickers
because the most Savvy you're going to
realize what Arbitrage is going on and I
want to make sure they take advantage of
that
awesome Todd thank you so much brother
Gary my pleasure great to be with you
man great you great to be collaborating
with you and Reebok I mean look if it
forget about even the holding the nft or
being an alpaca holder or the super
stickers just as a badass [__]
classic sneaker these are [__] fire
uh I'm getting quite a bit of comments
in the community of like people seeing
it or hearing about it for the first
time you will be able to be purchasing
these very shortly this is a great back
to school sneaker for a lot of people
I'm excited about that I'm humbled as a
47 year old who grew up in Jersey the
Reebok bananas for me you made it you
made it you made it brother and you made
it too from mail room to CEO Todd
krinsky thank you so much from Reebok
we'll talk soon
love you all
foreign